I used to remember to turn the light off
because I remember my mom always told me
to do that but now on such a small level
things like that I kind of make
decisions I leave a room and I come back
and turn a light off or any number of
countless things that's just the example
the common example that comes to my mind
but it's it's neat that there's that
little bug in your ear now that I think
that's really important while the
world's trying to figure out how to
solve the problem
awareness is probably the first step to
solving so the fact that you know we're
all everyone seems a little bit more
aware about it I know I went back and
you know I saw some of my parents habits
have changed a little bit I know they're
using the reusable grocery bags and
things like that and just to see all
generations kind of at least it being in
their head a little bit more that's
really exciting